Hello and welcome to today's episode.
Today, we are going to be taking a
look at Grafana, a dashboard and tool for
building out really cool dashboards with metrics and
understanding how your systems are operating.
That's a terrible description, but it'll get better
soon, I promise.
Before we start, I wanna thank my employer,
Equinix Medal. They provide the time for me
to actually produce the show and you know,
produce hopefully content that you all find
useful and help you learn.
We are giving away now
$50
promo code to anyone who is watching, who
wants to spin up some bare metal servers
on Equinix metal. The code is Rawkode
dash live. You can sign up today at
metal.equinix.com.
Now, I'm gonna invite on my wonderful guest,
Marcus Olson, a developer advocate from Grafana Labs.
Hey Marcus, how are you? Hey, I'm great.
Thanks for having me. Awesome. I'm very excited.
I'm a big fan of Grafana. I'm hoping
we can we can do some cool stuff
today. Yeah. Hope so too.
You like to just take a couple of
minutes and tell people about your role at
Grafana Labs and even you know, what Grafana
is?
Yeah, sure.
So I am a developer advocate at Grafana
Labs,
which is the company behind the open source
project Grafana.
And if you've never heard about Grafana before,
it helps to think of it as a
visualization
tool for systems monitoring.
That's really just a tip of the iceberg
though, but it kinda gets you going.
So my role at Grafana Labs is to
help users
get going, but also
up their game and
help them take advantage of everything that is
Grafana.
And
lately I've been also
focusing a lot on plugin development. So if
you're curious how to extend
Grafana
to your I don't know, integrate with your
special database or you wanna offer a new
type of visualization,
that's usually
me who's who you're gonna talk to.
So
more about Grafana.
I
so imagine that you know, you have this
application that you've built
and you're really proud of it, but how
do you know it actually works? How do
you know that it actually does the thing
that you promised it to do?
So that's really where Grafana comes in, where
Grafana
brings in metrics,
information,
statistics about that application
and then visualizes it, typically in graphs
over time. So you can see for example,
how is my application using resources
over the course of a day?
My
application
running on its,
know,
using too many resources during 8PM
or something like that.
But you know, that being said, we also
see a lot of people using it for
all kinds of crazy stuff.
I know there's a community
of beekeepers that are using Grafana to a
monitor their beehives,
which is really cool. I have a colleague
who just set up her
She's she's growing avocados
and she just set up her her monitoring
solution for just making sure that they have
what they need, they're growing
like they should. So it's very
commonly used for systems monitoring,
but we're seeing
just tons of different use cases for it.
Awesome. Yeah, I don't think there's probably anyone
in the technology,
at least in a sys admin operator SRE
rule who's not familiar with Grafana.
But to hear that it's actually now spread
now to all these other domains for beekeeping
and avocados.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I I guess as long
as you've got time series data and everything
that you track over time, Grafana is a
natural fit to to dashboard and visualize it
and and
yeah. That makes total sense to me. Yeah.
Alright. So we got a couple of hellos.
So let's go through that. John McCabe,
pleasure to have you back. Hello again.
Demo,
yo to you too. And Carlos, hey buddy,
how's it going?
Hey everyone.
So
let's see.
Let's cover the what have I prepared upfront,
which hopefully is as little as possible.
So if I go to to to
I have not installed Grafana. So we're starting
from the we're starting from scratch as far
as all the Grafana stuff goes. But I
have prepared a little bit of infrastructure on
Equinix metal, so that we can have some
metrics to actually work with today. I don't
wanna be doing metric collection in real time
and setting up, because it's not what we're
as important for today's session.
So I spun up a three bare metal
machines.
They
all have a Prometheus
node exporter running and they all have telegraph
running. They're collecting very similar metrics, host, desk,
network,
CPU memory, all the basic Linux stuff.
I also have on one node an influx
DB two running and a Prometheus running.
The reason I've kind of duplicated my effort
here is that one of the selling points
of Grafana is that it works with any
data source. So we were gonna take a
look at setting up and talk to be,
we'll take a look at Prometheus, we'll build
some dashboards, we'll import some dashboards.
And it'll all just go amazingly well and
nothing will break. Right, Mark? Absolutely
nothing.
Alright. Okay. So I've also prepared here the
download page for Grafana. So if anyone is
curious, you can follow along. But this is
just grafana.com/grafana/download.
I'm assuming the most recent version is this
one here from the 10/28/1973
o.
Yeah. Which is today.
Oh, so it is.
So congratulations.
You get to try out 7.3.
I mean, that sounds kinda dangerous, but I
love it. So we're gonna do that.
So we should get a terminal on the
first machine. So we're only gonna one run
one Grafana. I'll run that on the same
node as Prometheus and m fox d b.
So step one,
get on my machine.
And this is a bintu.
That
means I
can just run
this.
Yeah. Yeah. Sure work.
Things always start off so easy just to
kinda lure you into a false sense of
security and then it all goes downhill.
That's what I find every time I write
code. Like, I think I've got this. This
is easy. And then
Yeah. It's always the details they get you.
Oh, Grafana server. Okay.
Nice.
There you go.
So by default,
what
port is my Grafana gonna run on?
It's gonna be port 3,000.
Three thousand. You should yeah. You should be
able to access it from there. Oh, that's
my Prometheus. At least we know that works.
Yeah. I really should have checked everything again.
Yeah.
So I didn't set up any credentials.
What
do I do here, Mark? Sure. So the
first time you open up Grafana,
you'll you'll be given a default
admin
account which is admin,
a d m I n for both username
and password.
We'll have to change that right away. So
there is Well,
I think that you have Yeah. So if
you're just Yeah. The responsible thing to do
is just to change it right away.
I had to change my name and strategy
there for my fake password
Perfect. I obviously typed it in front of
everybody. Rawkode one two three. That is my
Google password too. Good luck everyone. Awesome.
Well, so yeah. I mean, once you logged
in,
first thing you'll see is the the home
dashboard as we call it, which is a
dashboard
just like the ones that you will create,
but it's a little bit more specific. So
it kinda helps you get going,
where to start, where to go next.
So yeah.
So we're not gonna follow this tutorial.
I mean, we're we're just gonna dive straight
on another data source. Right? We're feeling pretty
confident.
I think so. Let's let's go.
Alright. So we can see that Grafana supports
Prometheus,
Grafana,
OpenTDSDB,
and FluxDB,
and then oh, that there's loads here. I'm
not gonna list all of I mean, what
what I actually think is really cool about
Grafana is that it's it's, you know, it
started with basically
just being a visualization
tool for graphite,
but it's grown to support so many other
data sources. And by now it's it's not
that so when I said that, like seeing
it as a visualization towards just the tip
of the iceberg, I really mean it. It's
like, right now it's a platform where you
you you can connect all different type of
databases.
Grafana doesn't actually store anything itself. So all
the data is outside Grafana,
you control it. And if your database is
not supported, you can build a plugin to
make it appear in Grafana as well. So
this is just the ones that are built
in but yeah, you can write your own
integration.
Alright. Okay.
So
let's just start with Prometheus. This is the
first one on the list. I'm assuming that's
because most people are running Prometheus.
Like is there any rhyme or reason to
why Prometheus is is first? Yeah. So so
so we are
seeing a lot of users using Prometheus
and Influx and Grafite, OpenTSDB.
So they they are definitely
the most popular ones.
That's pretty much it.
We don't favor any
database over another but we are seeing a
lot of people using Prometheus for sure.
Alright.
Let me just make sure I still got
this IP address.
So my Prometheus
should be available
on port 9090.
Yeah. That's right.
And we've got access
server
or browser.
Yeah. So this is actually something that tend
to trip some people up that
the access mode is really how Grafana accesses,
know, your your server, in this case Prometheus.
So Grafana
is a server component and a front end
component.
So you can decide whether you want to
access your
data source through the browser or through the
server.
So typically,
yeah, you would pick server because of security
reasons for example, you might not want your
users to authenticate through the browser for example.
Yeah. So I'm assuming if I set any
sort of authentication here and set browser, does
the browser become aware of that authentication?
So going for the server is just a
safer way of doing that?
So
you could still use server and basic auth.
that would mean that the server,
the request originates from the server but you
still need to authenticate
to the endpoints
that you're you're getting the metrics from.
Okay. No problem.
So I haven't configured any
TLS, anything like that or CAs. This is
a a pretty wild setup that I did
very quickly. So I'm assuming I can just
have save and test here and we can
just
we get a green little banner there. So
I'm pretty comfortable. I love it. Yeah. Good.
And I'm just gonna add the influx one
while I'm here too. So
oh, okay. I can pick between influx q
l and flux. Well, I'm gonna go with
flux.
Yeah. That's that's
that's in beta right now. So we'll see
how that goes.
Token, token, token.
Good question.
I would just pop over here for thirty
seconds and
grab my token and a nice secure friendly.
And I even remembered the influx password.
Generally, that's the thing I forget. Okay. Mhmm.
So
copy.
Perfect. I'm pretty sure the bucket was Rawkode
as well. So if I hit save and
test, we get green. Wonderful.
Cool. That means I haven't broken anything since
I set it all up, which I'm happy
with.
Alright. So
we have two data sources.
I mean, I I guess now what I
wanna do is is start creating some of
these metrics that I've been writing into these
TSTPs for the last couple of hours.
What's step on there?
I think yeah. The the the first step
is to check out the explorer.
So in earlier versions of Grafana,
you would go straight to create a dashboard.
But it does involve a little bit of
setting up. So if you're just want to
explore,
play around with the data, look what's there,
I think explore is a great
first step.
Yeah, so
at the top you can select
which one of the data sources you wanna
query.
And
you get a little cheat sheet
as to what you can
query.
I think you can click on them to
auto
complete them but
Alright.
So
we'll
with Prometheus because there's no one fox d
b cheat sheet and that means I'm gonna
have to remember stuff. Which
I'm which I'm happy to I I will
remember of course. But we'll start with Prometheus.
Yeah. Sure. And see. So if I click
on metrics here. So it's actually gonna list
all of the metrics names that we have
available. Yeah.
You don't actually have to. Okay.
So
let's start with
Yeah. You can check out Node maybe.
Yeah. You you you get a lot of
metrics from the Node exporter.
Just pick your favorite one.
Yeah. That's a good one.
I Yeah.
So it looks like it's running.
You see the little progress up there? Yeah.
There
you go.
Now that says showing only 20 time series
show. Okay. So that takes quite a while
there because there's
sorry. I'm not I'm not really sure. Why
does that take a little while? What does
eleven fifty two mean here? That's a lot
of time series you got there. And the
most likely scenario is that you have
a lot of labels that are very
that are varying a lot.
I'm
trying to see what kind of labels you
have.
See if I can zoom in on this
a little bit.
Computer says no.
Why won't you zoom?
Let's try it from this photo here.
So what you could do,
it could be that you have a
Yeah, you could have a lot of
That's a good question.
So
for every value
of a label
here,
you get another time series.
So even though it looks like we've only
queried
one single time series in node CPU seconds
total, that is actually gonna return a bunch
of time series
for every value, you know, every permutation of
the the labels
that you have down there.
So
we might
if you know, maybe we can limit the
instance. I'm not sure how many instances you're
getting the metrics from.
We can also limit the mode.
So maybe maybe we want to see
how much CPU
we're currently using maybe. So let's
I think you can
select
the idle mode and just
Well, my tab there was giving up on
life.
Uh-huh. Alright.
I
may even pop this open and Chrome if
that happens again. But let's see what happens
now. Yeah. Alright. So Sure. Let's pick something
that's maybe not as verbose to start with.
Let's try
up. Right? That should just be a single.
There we go. Yeah. Nice and fast. There
you go.
Yeah. So the up is a great,
you know, good time series to just check
that everything is working.
You can alert on it, you know.
So it's a good good start.
Looks like it's working though. Yeah. And each
one of these is just my
each copy of the node exporter, I guess.
Yeah. I think so.
Let's see why I've got four here. So
I think Prometheus scraping itself plus I've got
a node export machine and then three. Yeah.
Okay. Cool. Yeah.
Alright. Let's try taking a look at
I don't know what APT is.
Could
it be Aptitude from Ubuntu?
I don't know. I don't know. Maybe it's
actually Maybe the node exporter does some apps.
Yeah. Maybe. I'm not sure. Oh yeah. Upgrades
pending. There we go. Oh, that's cool. I
didn't know that.
Oh, well, we'll learn together.
So this is okay. So it's just yeah.
It's obviously checking the app cache behind the
scenes pulling down the updates. Yeah. Alright. How
do we
try and so when we were looking at
the
those node metrics and maybe I'll just pick
another one and hopefully we get a bit
luckier with a number. Let's try this guy
on now.
Yeah. See this look at that. A blurb.
Although this isn't a counter, which is what
I was gonna say. Because it Grafana gave
me a hint. It was like, hey, this
is a counter type. You probably you don't
want to view this raw. You actually want
to calculate some sort of aggregation over time.
So So
Let's try.
Not a counter.
Maybe I'll risk it just to CPU again.
Although, I think base total should be a
counter to be fair.
Yeah. That that's a heavy one.
I mean, we could try to limit the
number of time series, but
yeah, that's a good question.
So yeah, it gave me this here.
So it says metric node CPU seconds total
as a counter. So I'm assuming it's understanding
what Prometheus is returning over the API and
then trying to give me a little bit
of hints about how I should actually visualize
this. So if I run a rate over
five minutes.
Yeah.
You what you could also do is just
to limit for like one machine or something.
If you just wanna make it a little
more responsive,
Heather.
Okay. Let let's do that then. So let's
see if I remember how to do this.
If I grab the IP address, I can
come in here.
Yeah. There we go. Exactly.
And And
instance. Instance
equals.
Oh, it's actually giving me complete. Nice.
Yeah.
So I can just hit run. Yeah. See
if that
It's still quite chunky.
That is curious.
Yeah. I wonder why you're
a lot of time series. So Oh, how
many CPUs do you have? Yeah. It looks
like you have 10 CPUs on
every
Yeah. That's gonna multiply
the time series, but I think it's fine.
Okay. Well,
we've added the Prometheus data source. We've done
a little bit of querying on the Prometheus
side. Let's jump over to the influx DB
side and then let's take and then I
think from conversations that we've had is that
there's some dashboards that are available online open
source that would actually allow us to create
a quick step or monitoring of these machines.
So we can take a look at that
too.
And I'm gonna close this tab because it
just
the minute I do that query, it breaks.
And I think it's just my setup. I
don't think it's anything
Grafana related.
Alright. So let's take a look. This is
the influx DB query thing. So this is
the new beta stuff that you you said
is is pretty new. So this is working
with influx DB two and their new query
language flux.
Now let's see if I remember how to
do the thing.
Okay.
Forget if I could zoom this in.
Oh, there we go.
I may have to zoom it back out
when I'm done. But so the flux syntax,
I can see from bucket
range
start
one day ago. In fact, let's just do
one hour
and then filter.
I I could just do that. Right? And
that will return all the metrics.
That's a good question.
I haven't had the chance to play with
flux yet. So I'm in your hands right
now. That's alright. I've
got at least 5% confidence in my ability.
Good enough.
Did it run?
Yeah. It did. Okay. So I can see
we've got CPU.
Oh.
Yeah. It did. Okay. So let's just filter
this on that same metric filter
function
row
row dot
CPU
usage
guest.
Fine.
Let's just let's see what happens. Alright.
Run.
Have I broke it?
Looks like it ran.
So I'm a little bit confused by this
graph here. This is showing
I mean, it's not my filter here. Right?
So I said filter only show me this
measurement where CPU usage gets nice, but I
can still see the bolt d b one
here.
I mean, how is there any way for
me to debug this?
If you try first try to run the
query again. Maybe
Yeah. Doesn't okay.
That's a good question.
You can try the query inspector
that that you can if you look under
the query field
to the right,
you go.
If you check the core inspector, I think
you can see what the actual
yeah, that's what you're getting back.
You can also check what your request was
if you're
Alright. I'm gonna cheat. If you're unsure.
Let's pop over here. I'm gonna just copy
a query so that it's not
I don't need to remember anything. So let's
hit go.
Maybe I'm maybe I'm monitoring too much. Alright.
Go away. So let's run this again. There
we go. Now I just need to fix
this because these variables won't exist.
Stop as an important.
Let's see if that works.
So if I just pop open this response,
got a data frame.
I have no idea what that means. Yeah.
That that's not very helpful, admit. That's yeah.
That's
that's the action the the the encoded data
frame. That's not gonna help be helpful for
you right now.
Yeah. If you close that
okay. It didn't seem to get any time
series from that.
Alright. Let's forget that then.
Wait. We just forget the index speedy stuff
never happened because of
okay. So
Grafana has this ability to explore metrics. We
kinda got that working. Mhmm.
Probably it would have helped if I understood
the data model a little bit more about
what I'm I'm throwing into this thing, but
we're just making up as we go along.
Mhmm. Now the explore
visual the explore thing here. Right? That's really
good for kind of ad hoc. Like, I
don't really know what I wanna understand yet.
Right? Like, would you say that the default
application of Grafana would be that, you know,
you go to dashboard. So you you pre
built so you understand the systems a little
bit better. That makes sense?
Yeah, for sure. If you're not really sure
yet what you wanna monitor, I would say
explore is great.
Dashboards
is kinda, you know, curated
insights. You know, you you you figure out
what you want and then you curate
a dashboard with the information that you actually
want to see in in a like a
at a glance
view.
So yeah, I think the next step is
to go in and create a dashboard possibly.
Okay.
So let's see.
Yeah. You can go to the plus in
the side menu, that works too.
Yeah.
Alright. So dashboard has something called panel. I
click add panel.
And
this
okay. So I can just build up my
query the same way I did on the
explorer view. Right? Yes. Yes. So if I
wanna track the app upgrades I've been pending
over time
Yep. Then we can see that graph pretty
quickly there.
Alright.
Yeah. So it yeah. It's basically the same
as you had in explorer.
So you can you can take that into
I I think at some point, if not
already,
we we should have a feature to go
from explore and then just create it in
the dashboard as well. I know that you
can go from the panel to explore mode,
but I think that we're working on getting
the
two ways as well.
Okay, that makes sense. So
how much control do I have over this
visualization?
Can I tweak this? Can I change What
are my options? Yeah, sure.
So we
basically have three parts to what we're seeing
right now. Right now we're in the edit
mode of a panel.
And
I guess the simplest way of explaining is
that a panel is really a query and
a visualization.
And
what you see where you already went was
the query editor, that's the one that's down
to the left.
And then you have to the right, you
have the panel editor,
which is responsible for controlling
how we visualize data. So you can set
the title, you can add a description and
stuff like that. That is more general for
all panels.
And then the next session section you'll see
is
yeah.
I'm just clicking stuff. Sorry. Nice. Very nice.
So the next section is the visualization section.
And then here you will actually get the
chance to select a visualization
that is more appropriate for the data you
wanna visualize.
So you got a bunch of built in
ones here, but again, you can extend this
with
more visualizations
from plugins.
But in this case, I think we can
just go with the graph for now. Yeah,
think that makes sense. Yeah.
And for the So the next sections are
more specific to this visualization
type, which is the graph.
So, yeah,
you can you can set it to be
bars, lines,
got points,
can set all kinds of stuff here. I
usually go when it when it comes to,
you know, time series, I usually prefer the
lines.
And this is just a personal taste, but
I I actually like to remove the the
the area fill.
So
I don't actually see I only see the
lines, but it's totally up to you. You
can you can choose however you like.
If you wanna get fancy, you can even
set a gradient for the the fill as
well. So
Oh. Yeah, exactly.
Killer feature, I know.
Yeah, these things are important when you gotta
look at them all day.
Exactly.
Also
staircase
could be
a good option for you as well depending
on how your data looks like. So
if you only have discrete
points, you
don't wanna show them interpolated.
So staircase helps you to really show where
the
points are.
And
what have we?
Yeah. You can can stack the the
time series as well.
Of course, stacking has some problems
as well in in terms of understanding
what is actually happening in the graph. But
if if your use case
needs stacking
visualization,
then there you go.
Yeah. You can you can change the the
units of each
axis.
So you would have to know up ahead
of time what
unit the data source is returning.
Yeah. We're
we're working on adding more, you know, hints
from the data source to let, you know,
the the
the visualization do better guess at what units
should be set.
But for now,
just just you have to know what what
unit. If you're using Prometheus then then you
have a little idea because usually you see
bytes or you get you see seconds or
whatever
could be.
Okay. But yeah, so you have some options
here. And
for the graph,
if you scroll down you have something called
series overrides which is really the next, if
you really want to dig in there,
I think you have to scroll up a
little, no, a little more,
there. There we go. Series overrides.
And this lets you set
custom
settings for each time series.
So
do a regular
expression for the time series you wanna adjust
for. So you can set one time series
to be points or
another
to be bars and so on.
So if you really wanna dig into it,
that's where you go.
This,
a little background,
the series overrides was something
that's been very powerful,
but it's really been only available for a
couple of visualizations,
graph being one of them. So
for seven point o,
this is now possible for any visualization.
And so that's the tabs up there
that you see, that's kind of the next
steps.
So that's the evolution of series overrides.
So there's a there's a lot of work
go
moving over to a new
platform
in in Grafana.
And
the actually the graph is you'd think that's
the first thing that you would migrate to
the new platform, but it's actually one of
the trickiest parts of Grafana.
So
we're working on it right now. So
it's not been completely migrated to the
you know, field overrides
model yet.
Okay. So I've got a suggestion then.
Right now, complete
serendipity,
I guess, but we're we're actually graphing something
that's very easy for us to change. I
mean, CPU would have been the same. We
could have ran up a process on it
and try to spike it or whatever. But
the upgrades is actually probably the easiest thing
because I can just go and upgrade one
of these boxes and really change this graph
instantly. So
what I've seen here and this is where
I'm gonna throw an idea at you and
we'll see how
painful this might be. But I see alerts
and I'm wondering, can we create an alert
that when a package
when the number of packages available for upgrade
goes to zero, we do something
and like Yeah. We can try. The thing.
Like You can try.
Alright. So if I say zero packages
is the name of my other I'm just
making this up. Feel free to correct whenever
I get this wrong. But see how I
valued it. Can I do five seconds?
Yeah. Should be able to. And we're looking
at the last five minutes.
If I I mean, I could just match
that. Right? So it's Yeah. So
the yeah. Four is if you if you
put a really high number or duration on
four, then we're not gonna see anything for
five minutes probably.
So it makes sense to I can also
set the last value here as well. So
I guess that means if the four was
over a wider period, but we're only looking
at the last value which should hopefully be
zero when I run this and Yes.
But
So
evaluate every five seconds, that's just gonna evaluate
that conditions.
But in order for that alert to trigger,
it needs to
be
evaluated
to true for a full five minutes or
five seconds in this case.
Before you will actually get an alert.
So that's why you want in this case,
you want something low. That makes sense. I
get that. I was completely wrong with my
naive understanding there, but I've got it now.
Okay. So with this, when last of query
I mean, can I drop this down? Let's
say 10.
We try and get this alert to go
quickly and Mhmm.
See when you just click stuff and it's
just a quite intuitive. It's Mhmm. It's great.
So I'm gonna say below one.
No.
No data. We can ignore that. So send
alert to.
Yeah. So you would have to set up
a notification
channel. So you would have somewhere to send
this.
Ah,
okay. So is that something I can just
click
go from
here?
Yes.
So you would go to
No. You have another tab in the side
menu. There you go. Notification channels.
What are my options and email?
Oh, then I'll have to configure some sort
of Yeah.
To h t t p?
Yes. You can.
You can do you can do a web
hook. So it sends a post
to a URL.
So one of my friends built this thing
called rbox.
App that gives you
an endpoint.
Oh, that's that's that's awesome.
The service I've been using for doing that,
they have started charging,
I believe. So I haven't really been using
that lately.
Okay. I'll look at this one.
Rawkode. So I I had test. I refreshed
Rawkode and I can see the request came
through just fine. So we now have an
alerted endpoint. Right? Is that it?
Yeah. So now we have somewhere to send
the alert. So you should be able to
wonder if you might have to update this.
So if you go ahead and save the
the dashboard first.
I don't think we did that.
Let's
call this David.
Save. Yeah. Cool. So if you go back
now and and sign the
Okay. The alert channel. So my alert is
still here. The only thing I need to
do now is,
oh yeah. Send it to our box. Message
details.
No updates.
Yeah. Let's see if emojis work.
Test rule.
Yeah.
So
that
tell me that it's not gonna fire, which
I guess is to be expected right now.
Right?
Firing false, state okay, condition of false, false
equals false. Wait. I
wonder if
So if you check your R box, see
Did you actually get a request? I think
you can
Let's see.
Yeah.
And that is the first request.
Yes. That's that's just
the test request I think. Isn't it? Yeah.
Yeah. So we never got another. Yeah.
So let's
let's
say I view the last five minutes and
this
So we can turn on auto refresh in
five seconds.
Mhmm.
So in theory,
if
making stuff up, find my app. Oh, no
back. There we go. I can run
upgrades.
It's going pretty fast.
This is refreshing. Let's just
make this a bit bigger.
I'm assuming within the next five, ten,
fifteen ish seconds, we should see one of
these time series
essentially fall off a cliff down to zero.
Right?
Maybe?
Oh, it's still running. Oh, there's a kernel
upgrade in there. So that may just take
a few seconds.
Oh, we have a couple more comments. Sheidan
says, hey, folks. Hey, Sheidan. Thank you for
joining us.
I'm not sure at what point you got
your monkey eyes closed and mind blowing, but
that's cool. Thanks.
Okay. So our app upgrade is finished.
Let's see if we get another refresh here.
And
not what I was expecting.
So Well, it could also be depending on
the scrape interval of Prometheus.
Or if it's set to fifteen or thirty
seconds, it could take up to that long
for Prometheus actually.
Oh, yeah. That's a good point actually. The
scrape interval in Prometheus is set to ten
seconds.
Okay.
So yeah, I guess we may just have
to There you go. I think, yeah, something
happened.
Oh, no. Okay.
God.
Diagonal bit. And
then let's just do the
blast everything approach.
Everything is. Okay. So we should have a
zero. We should have a zero.
Might not be what we
what we thought it would be.
Yeah. That's what I get for making it.
I just assumed,
which is obviously the first problem that I
made here. That this was tracking the number
of dependencies the app thought was available.
Alright. Let's go to let's okay. So we're
still making progress here. We've got a dashboard
now. Let's save this.
Save.
I can click on David here and there's
my dashboard. So I can add another panel.
Right? Mhmm. Here. Okay.
Let's do maybe do something a little bit
more traditional.
So
something I guess we'd want to alert on
would be the
the disk utilization.
Let's go with that. Right? I can I
can write a massive fail for the disk?
So in order to alert on that, what
we wanna do is
pick a metric. So this is gonna be
node.
Yeah. I think you have in some file
system. Was it available?
Disk.
So that's regrade bytes. Alright.
Let's
see what have we got available here. Oh.
I really should have switched to Chrome. I've
been persistent with this with Valid thing for
a while.
Oh, so that's the sky. Oh, yeah. We
probably don't want that.
I think you want this file Yeah.
That one. Oh, we can actually see.
Was that my app running?
That we because we would have modified the
disk. Right? So the baits that are available
would would have dropped and then Yeah. To
remove the cache and then it would have
freed up a little bit. So okay. So
cool. We can we can we can identify
that.
So let's
and we can see the three root file
systems from each of my devices. So I'm
just gonna hit
apply.
And
can I
put these state by state?
Yeah.
I think it's
easier if you resize them first.
Okay.
Cool. There you go.
So let's try and
see if right into our desk is gonna
cause this. We've still got our five second
refresh going on. We can still see this
that. I've dragged them side by side but
because
I probably actually wanna make that bigger for
everybody. Right? Because the zoom isn't too great
on this browser. So there we go.
Alright. Let's write big fail.
So
input
dev
random
output
my
big
fail.
Did you set an alert? Was that what
you wanted to do? Or
or you I just wanted to confirm that
this worked first. Oh, gotcha. Gotcha.
So in theory, we should wait the ten
seconds for the Prometheus node export to detect
Yeah. Makes new values or five second refreshes
running here. I'm assuming this is gonna be
the same.
This blue line should be the same machine,
the same server.
Yep. And there we go. We can start
to see that lane just stepping on the
end there. Right? Yeah. I'm not making that
up.
Alright. So let's add an alert.
So what do we got bates wise here?
219,000,000,000.
Oh, there we go. It's dropping.
But we've got enough disk space there that
we can survive and weather a little bit
of that d d running. So let's
oh.
Edit.
Alert.
Create.
So I guess I just do last again.
Five seconds five seconds.
We set this to 10
and is
below.
Is there an easier way for me to
kind of have a relative value to where
it is right now at all?
Or am I just gonna have to start
typing numbers?
Check the the condition if you might have
if you like instead of last, I'm thinking
you might have
a percent def maybe.
I haven't really used it so
I'm learning now as well. I I think
that's what you want. Like if it drops
drops too fast for example.
Okay. So if it drops more than
well, it's not gonna drop 10% in ten
seconds.
So
let's just go with the big number approach.
At least then I don't have to build
up a mental model of what I'm actually
expecting to happen. So 217,000,000,000.
2 1 6 1 2 3. So that's
200,000,
2 million,
20 million, 2 hundred million, 2 billion. Right?
Mhmm.
Yeah. You can also see where the alert
is in the graph right now. So Oh,
nice. Oh, Yeah. You can even drag that
with the handle if you wanna adjust it
down to the right on the actual pop
up. Yeah. I think yeah. You can probably
drag the whole Done.
Yeah.
Alright. In fact, I can just
it's it's going pretty fast. Okay. Let's stop
the thing. Right?
Yeah. What you can do is also to
set a a a minimal value of the
the the axis so you don't have to
fight. Because right now it's it's taking the,
you know the the it's auto adjusting.
So you can instead set a fixed
min value of the axis
to help you with that. Alright. Well, so
we're not writing to the disc anymore. So
let's just
leave that there. That's just below where we
want it to be. I've clicked our box.
We'll see disk
going
to fall
over.
And apply.
Done.
And
is this my alert lane that's here?
Yeah. That that's the threshold of
where it will start,
you know, evaluating.
So the the alert might not trigger right
away depending on our settings to
you know, to avoid spikes.
So you know, if if it spikes over
the or under in this case, the the
threshold line, then and then it's back to
normal, then we might not, you know, send
the alarm just yet. So we might want
to have it triggering
for
for a few minutes at least or
So I've noticed something. There's a broken heart
on this one. Yes. What does that mean?
That means that one of your alerts is
firing right now. So it finally noticed my
updates.
Is that right? Yeah. I think so.
Right. Well, let's let's probably task. So let's
run that one again. We'll cause this one
to get me a broken heart.
Can I zoom in? Oh, I can. Yeah.
So if you hover those little triangles
at the bottom, you can see yeah. Oh
yeah. App update is pending zero. Okay. So
it just took a little bit of time
whatever's
happening with the Prometheus export. You know, the
Prometheus export probably
doesn't
check for updates in the app cache every
ten seconds. Like that would be probably have
a negative performance on my machine. Like it
probably does that over a wider interval. Couldn't
yeah.
That's a plausible reason.
I'll I'll go with it. So in theory,
if I refresh here.
Yeah. We do. There's a little smiley.
There he goes. It worked the first name.
Says,
that's so cool. Yeah. I'm glad that worked
the spell. I wasn't nervous. So
awesome. So the app update trick worked. We
can come back to the main dashboard.
Is my DD running? It is
woah. It went the wrong way.
I'm not sure. For a bit. Don't have
no idea why. Oh. Because I just blew
away this device by rewriting over the top.
Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Causing
actually freed up to this space, which was
clever.
And now it's got to climb back down
to where the thing is here. So let's
just leave that for a few minutes. We
have already seen a work in the layer.
That was really cool. I'm happy with that.
Yeah. Let's we've got about ten minutes left.
So shall we import a dashboard that maybe
makes a bit more sense of our metrics
than us? Yeah. We'll try it. We'll try
it. So
if if
you go to grafana.com/dashboards,
you've got a ton of community built dashboards
that you can use.
I think there is one that if you
just search for node export exporter.
And if you search or sort by downloads,
I think that you're gonna get
one that is
pretty Yeah, the the first one there.
If you click that one.
So if you look in at the the
the right, you see copy ID to clipboard.
So now we can go to Grafana
again.
If you just switch tab.
Yep. And then
go to, yes, that one, manage.
And then you can click import to the
right there. Yep. And then in the in
the top field
yep.
I mean it's just so intuitive.
Yes. And you need to set
the the data source you wanna use. But
that should be it.
Oh, there you go. There you go.
Thank you community.
Yeah. There's no way
I was building that and
that that's comprehensive.
Wow.
Yeah. It's got a lot of Would would
you mind just like there's
more than just the graphs that we've looked
at so far here. Can you just maybe
pack out a few of these different visualizations
and and tell us what they are? Yeah.
Sure. So the
on the top we see something called a
gauge.
So the gauge is typically like something you
would see in a car, know.
It has a lower number and a
higher number. So it lets you visualize
something that can,
you know,
something that has
a upper limit and a lower limit, basically.
So disk usage, for example. If you wanna
know that
wait, you're reaching a certain
percentage of disk available or something like that,
then you could use a gauge
because you can set thresholds.
Actually, if you go to one of the
the gauges
and
edit them, I think that we can adjust
the
thresholds.
I believe if you go to field,
the field tab to the right, yeah. And
then you scroll scroll down to the threshold
sections. Yeah. You can change
that as well.
So now the maximum, yeah, would be 10%.
If I set it to,
yeah, it's almost full. Yeah, exactly.
Alright. I'll put it back to a hundred.
Yeah. Alright. And if you scroll down to
the the
threshold sections that
you can set those
orange,
when it goes to orange, when it goes
to red.
So
you can try it now if you wanna
just update those to something,
yeah, like that.
Alright. So let's say red is seven, we
should be orange. Alright. Nice. Okay. Cool.
Yeah.
So
it's up to you. It's just a visual
indication of when things are starting to go
wrong
to catch them ahead of time.
Oh, you can actually do percentages as well.
Yep. So
it can be a bit more dynamic then
depending on that means, you know, if I'm
setting the max here, then the percentage do
seem like a much better workflow here.
Cool. Nice. Yeah.
Let's see what else we have.
And another one that's very heavily used as
the staff panel,
which I think you got to the yeah.
The This one? This one. Yep.
So if you edit edit yeah. I think
you can edit that one.
I could have I could click. There we
go. Yeah. Compare it so hard for me.
So
this dashboard is using the the old version
of this panel.
So that's why it's asking you to migrate
to the newer version in this case. Can
I just click that? Good
question. Try it.
Yo, there you go. Easy as pie. So
what's different between the old
what's this called? A stat? A stat and
then your stat? Yes. So there the main
difference is the underlying technology.
Grafana used to be written angular
and is now migrated to React.
So
this led us to do a lot of
bunch of new and cool things.
And that's that's one of the major reasons.
Okay. I would say
If I know React, I can write my
own visualizations,
my own Oh, for sure. Panels. Nice. For
sure. So,
yeah, you can use
A panel visualization
is basically just a React component
with custom properties.
So for sure you can write your own
one.
But yeah, so the stat panel is good
for if you have like these KPIs
that you
wanna report to upper management.
How many concurrent users do we have at
this moment?
Like
numbers that you wanna copy real quick. That's
that's a great use
of
stat panels.
But as you can see, graphs are really
the yeah.
That's really the main one
that you'll want to use.
But it's just so interesting you know, going
through these and seeing how my machine is
is operating by looking at all these you
know,
these these peaks and troughs and you know,
there's a lot of things that are pretty
static. You know, the temperature obviously isn't gonna
change too much.
System d, I mean
For sure it's a different kind of doom
doom scrolling.
Yeah. You you can you can sit here.
You can you can see that d d
command kinda consistently
across as as we scroll down. At least
the first spike on I'm not sure what's
going on with the most recent one again.
I could just do my Prometheus setup,
which
this is all really cool. So Grafana,
you know, based on what we've covered, I'll
just pop back over here.
You know, based on what we've covered now
and like an hour Grafana is just this
multi
data source visualization
and dashboarding tool. But so much more beyond
that. Like, you know, we never even touched
on the transformations, but there's a whole lot
of things that we can do and these
panels with the data on the fly and
the alerting was really cool as well. Like
there's just so much power in this. Like
I think we're easily gonna have to do
another six of these and I'm just gonna
send you up right now. So Yeah. That's
okay. I'll I'll be happy to come back.
Alright. Can do a lot more. Do you
have any closing thoughts before
we before we finish up for today?
No. Just that if you're if you wanna
get started with Grafana and if you're having
any issues, feel free to reach out to
me on Twitter
or
any any place where you see my name.
Just
and I'll get you get you if I'm
not able to answer myself, I can certainly
get you to the person who can.
Alright.
Well, thank you very much for joining me
today. It's been an absolute pleasure. You know,
I'm looking forward to doing more sessions on
Grafana and starting to help people unleash a
little bit more of the power that it
brings available to our infrastructure.
So thanks again. If anyone has any questions,
leave them in the comments. I'll make sure
that we try and follow-up afterwards as well.
And stay tuned, we will be back with
more Grafana in the future. Thanks again. Have
a nice day, Marcus. You too. Bye. Bye.